so we're asked what is the charge of a
calcium ion with 18 electrons so pause
this video and see if you can work that
on your own and I will give you a little
bit of a tip a periodic table of
elements might be useful to see where
calcium sits on that periodic table of
elements so why don't you pause this
video and see if you can figure out the
charge of that calcium ion
all right so what defines the element is
actually how many protons it has and
that's what we have right over here its
atomic number is 20. that's how many
protons it has so we could say number of
protons which provide positive charge is
20 and then we know the number of
electrons is 18. that's negative charge
so I'll just write it here number
electrons all right I'll abbreviated
right over there or I'll shorten it that
is 18 and this has negative charge so if
you want to know the net charge you take
the number of protons the positive
charge and subtract out the number of
electrons and so that leaves you with
positive two charge 20 minus 18 is
positive 2 and we will denote that with
a 2 plus so some people might write this
as calcium two plus just like that to
show that it is a calcium ion it's
likely the situation maybe where the
calc calcium originally had 20 electrons
and 20 protons so then it would not be
an ion it would just be a neutral atom
but maybe it lost those it lost two of
those electrons and so then it got a
positive two or a two plus charge let's
do another example over here so if I
were to ask you what is the charge of an
ion that has seven protons eight
neutrons and 10 electrons
pause this video and think about what
that would be
well we can confirm that that indeed
would be an ion because it has a
different number of protons than it does
electrons and if you want to figure out
the charge you just take the number of
protons seven which are the positive
charges and you subtract out the
negative charges that's why you're
subtracting you subtract out the
electrons so 7 minus 10 that would be
equal to negative three and so I would
say you'd often denote that as saying a
3 minus charge and if you wanted to
write down what that what ion that is
what's going to go back to the periodic
table of elements we can see that if you
have seven protons by definition you are
talking about nitrogen so that would be
a nitrogen ion that you would denote
like that it has a negative 3 or 3 minus
charge